hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 190 189 189
like I said like I now have said some
people have begun to Tire of the fact
that we never know what number it is yes
or you never know what number it is it's
funny how um something about the runup
to the live stream never puts figuring
out what number it is at the uh top of
the priority list but uh for
for me yes that is that is the sad fact
I mean there are bigger defects to have
but I I acknowledge it's a defect and uh
for those of you who are suffering from
my defect I uh I
apologize so here we are yes I am Dr
Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather Hy
and um we are here going um more than
three years we've been doing this and
we're gonna we're going to keep doing it
bringing you uh some of what seems to be
going on in the world today viewed
through an evolutionary lens indeed here
at Darkhorse uh we're on Rumble now and
we're also on locals and the watch party
is happening on locals right now we
strongly encourage you to join the live
conversation that is happening there uh
and we got lots of stuff going on at
locals now we did our private Q&A there
this last Sunday we're releasing guest
episodes early there all for uh paying
members on locals so we strongly
encourage you to to join the Darkhorse
community on locals all right um we're
going to talk about uh free speech today
uh little some orwellian stuff going on
you know a little a a smidge sprinkl
sprinkle of Orwell here a a dash of
Huxley there um and the developing brain
and uh G tropen releasing hormone and
agonists thereof and various other
things possibly be an Agonist of um
developmental
hormones you mean antagonist antagonist
right an Agonist oh sure no you're right
we should all be agonists of the
category in general yes yes yes uh so
yeah we'll we'll we'll get there um but
first uh as always we have our sponsors
whom we um whom we appreciate greatly we
have three sponsors right at the top of
the show they are this week's seed House
of macademia is and American Hartford
gold and without further Ado we'll bring
those ads to you our first sponsor this
week is seed a probiotic that really
works if if you've tried probiotics
before and got nothing out of it try
seed it's designed differently from
other probiotics it's designed better it
actually works you're gotten your immune
system work together coordinating your
body's response to the world both around
and within you seed helps improve the
health of your gut microbiome which
means it supports you becoming healthier
overall our resonant gut microbes
directly impact the development and
function of the immune system even
before we're born microbes inform our
immune
system uh teaching our
sorry just wanted to make sure I was in
the right week am I in the right week uh
by definition is it number
189 oh you're asking me now
well the shoes on the other hand now 189
part that has nothing to do with this no
um okay even before I'm talking about
seed the probiotic which is awesome
which I took uh just this morning as I
as one does as you should as I do even
before we're born microbes inform our
immune system teaching our body how to
distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that our body does not
recognize as its own you can support
your gut immune axis in a variety of
ways including by prioritizing sleep new
research suggests that the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy you
can also support your gut immune axis by
taking seeds ds01 daily synbiotic seed
is a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strains that have been
clinically or scientifically studied for
their benefits 16 of those 24 strains
are specifically geared towards
digestive health and four of the 24
probiotic strains are known to promote
healthy skin your skin like your gut has
its own microbiome seed supports both
gut and skin Health seed is free from 14
major classes of allergens including but
not limited to sugar animal products soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and
corn shellfish should be included in
animal products shouldn't it be oh F
Genetically speaking this is a slam dunk
also
corals I suspect this is free of coral
yeah I think they just I don't know it's
a major class of allergen though that's
probably why no it's bad for your teeth
though it's wears them down was the last
I would be unless you're a parrot fish
which I am not ah good to know and seed
is basically double hul with its capsule
in capsule design it is engineered to
maintain viability through your
digestive tract until it reaches your
colon where you want it and the same
design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary this is
actually huge um you can you know you
can travel with it uh you can keep it in
your medicine cabinet uh you don't have
to be precious about it like you do with
a lot of uh probiotics seeds daily
symbiotics supports gut skin and heart
health and micronutrient synthesis we've
heard from several people including us
who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse to redeem 25% off
your first month of seeds ds01 daily Sy
biotic that is seed seed.com Darkhorse
and use code
Darkhorse our second sponsor this week
is House of macadamias tree nuts are
delicious and nutritious and generally
high in fat and low in carbs unlike what
various food pyramids and government
agencies might have led you to believe
high fat low carb foods are increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you yet more reason not to trust
either food pyramids or most government
agencies but each species of nut is
different requiring a special mindset
and and appropriate Footwear Brett clogs
for some waiting shoes for others
regardless of what shoes you have
available to you though like us you are
likely to find that macadamias are the
best nut there is what footwear do you
like when you're eating macadamias I
when eating macadamias I do not stick to
one type of Footwear I have uh something
casual on the left foot and something a
bit more formal on the right oh that's
good yeah yeah that creates sort of aing
it leaves you prepared for whatever may
happen you just I think it actually
leaves you equally unprepared for
everything that is also correct
excellent macademia nuts take a very
long time to grow and because they are
both rare and highly sought after they
have the dubious distinction of being
the world's most expensive nut the segue
from the shoes was really poor there
it's my doing what segue yeah between
the taste and the health benefits though
they're worth it they have even fewer
carbohydrates than most other nuts which
makes them the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose they're also uniquely rich
in Omega sevens including especially
polyic acid an unsaturated fat that has
been linked to Natural collagen
production fat loss and heart health and
house the Macadamia is intent on making
this amazing food accessible to everyone
they have partnered with more than 90
farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks these include their dark
chocolate dip macadamias and a delicious
assortment of bars made with 45%
macadamia nuts and flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut but
our favorite product of theirs is are
are
are wow ISR the simple my verbs ISR is R
an is R conundrum is second only to an
is a conundrum which is famously
important so I think this is a no I
think you've missed the point we're
going to start we're going to start
declaring we're going to start uh
declaring our verbs our whoa yeah all
right that's next level I know I know
that's that that that is not brought to
you by house of macadamia but I hope
that they would endorse this this move
um our favorite product of theirs are
we'll just stick with r for now the
simple salted macadamia made with
namibian sea salt they are amazing we
love them and think that you will too
House of macadamia also makes a
delicious macadamia nut oil which is
100% cold pressed rich in
monounsaturated fatty acids and has a
higher smoke point than Olive Oil so is
well suited to high heat cooking and
baking and they've got this great new
macademia nut milk milk available in
individual packets that travel well so
you can add it to a a drink uh while
you're out our house of academias Highly
recommends House of macadamias for all
of your macademi needs for a limited
time House of macadamias is offering
listeners a free box of their
bestselling nabian sea salted macademia
nuts worth $35 with your purchase at
House of macadamias docomo horse and $20
off your whole order with code Darkhorse
once again that's www. House of
macadamias that's all a except for the
IM M AA D-
m.com use code Darkhorse for 2 20% off
every order you won't be sorry and I
just want to clarify that when it says
that is uh concordant with a keto diet
that can be with either
spelling concordant either spelling no
no like harmonics as far as I know
there's only one spelling of concordant
that is tolerable and even that one is a
bit iffy but
keto k t o right yeah and Q is there a u
in uh the capital city ofor exactly is
there a u in Kito yeah there is a u I
thought there was and then I there's
some word where there's no yeah I
probably should worry more cutter Q
cutter that's it nice cutter yeah um
which shouldn't be pronounced that way
or it shouldn't be spelled that way I
don't know which either one something's
got to something's got to change I think
it is pronounced that way and shouldn't
be spelled that way but you know it is
what it is it it does appear to be I
don't know I haven't been yes it might
not be what it
is I have to concede that not very good
but difficult to counter point totally
sober
right morning I mean right yeah it's
it's still morning for us yes all right
and for those of you in Hawai and for
everyone not listening live not everyone
some of you not listening live it's
morning in America and I leave you to
choose how you spell that all to
yourself morning or America uh morning
yes right M yeah no America that's again
um unambiguous on the spelling
front
Okay uh our final sponsor this week is
American Harford gold if you listen to
our course regularly then you already
know just how incompetent and unstable
many of our institutions are becoming
this must be an old script because they
have become incompetent and unstable
interest rates are Sky High we are
caught between runaway inflation and
recession we are assured that all is
fine while the cost of food housing
Medical Care schools and everything
climbs our leaders are increasingly
nonsensical all of this threatens
businesses jobs and retirement funds
finding ways to secure your nest egg and
insulate your wealth is more important
than ever and adding precious metals to
your assets is a great way of
stabilizing your Investments to protect
your uh your family's finances American
Heartford gold uh is a precious metals
dealer that can can help you do just
that American hardford Gold helps
individuals and families protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
metals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
that's important
with one short phone call they can have
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your IRA or 401K
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A+ rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they will give you up to
$5,000 of free silver on your first
qualifying order contact them today by
visiting the link in the episode
description below call
8668281166
82811109
99 8899 again that's 866 82811109
98899 all
right we're back thank
you I think the implication of the long
pause after well done suggests that that
was not the expectation the pause after
well done was entirely you're doing oh
okay not as well done as you had
thought
yes um so we've got two fairly different
um things to bring to you today uh would
you like to start or would you like me
to
start uh gez um you know I guess I could
start I could start um yeah uh I need
you uh to do a little beatboxing you
just go
abom you're not going to do that nope oh
all right uh well that leaves me without
not without warning nope not without not
without warning well all right we know
what kind of stick in the mud you are oh
do we not really but uh all right so
uh um let's talk about X baby Orwell and
Bradberry let's talk about all the good
things that have come from being free
let's talk about X let's talk about X
yes all right so my hope is that my
embarrassing myself in that way will
bring AES Elon Musk to that clip and
hopefully Elon if you're watching let me
just ask please brother unblock me um I
get it I I confess to the crime but the
punishment is is uh disproportionate I
will keep the DMS to a bare minimum but
uh something about Twitter is just not
the same when you can't see your tweets
because they're redacted so my God there
we are all right that is the intro what
what was Bradbury doing there was it
just a rhyme no Heavens No in fact if it
had just been a rhyme I would have used
Huxley yeah but Bradberry Fahrenheit 451
Fahrenheit per one y right so that's
more relevant than Huxley in this
particular case yeah that was good man
thank you yeah thank you um yeah that's
uh that's me showing my genx colors I
think okay I would have to look up when
that song it's salt and Peppa but if you
know given that you spell Peppa Peppa
I'm pretty sure that's a Gen X thing
probably yeah okay so the point of this
diversion embarrassing your son well
then I know I'm doing my job as a dad
because that's kind of how it works um
all right so the what I wanted to uh
deal with was a ju toos of two things
that uh crossed my Twitter feed in quick
succession um this week that I thought
made a rather interesting point so Zack
do you want to show um that tweet which
one um um the one the citing The
Washington Post
article now there's something
interesting going on here which I don't
quite understand I'm going to show you a
tweet which is going to show you a
headline and then we're going to show
you the article in
question all right so here is the tweet
that caught my attention and it is from
The Washington Post it says Elon Musk
stopped policing political
misinformation the tech industry
followed um and that I thought was a
fascinating admission to becoming from
The Washington Post the article now
reads show the live version of the
article
Zach all right Zach is bringing up the
live version of the article in which the
title appears different now I don't know
if this is because there are multiple
Pages associated with this or if they
actually changed the title so that it
now reads following Elon musk's lead big
Tech is surrendering to
disinformation
okay so the the headline in the Tweet
was something about not no longer
policing misinformation and now we are
surrendering to disinformation yes now I
am sure that there is some reason for
the two distinct headlines but I fail to
see how one is more protective of the
powers that be than the other frankly
they both strike me as a huge admission
um yeah I mean they both are a huge
emission although in the language you
know post post George Floyd and we are
now you know more than three years post
George Floyd but um the um
widespread accepted hatred of the police
and resistance being something that you
were sort of obligated to do it feels to
me like um policing is um always going
to have a negative well it will will
tend to have a negative veillance in an
outlet like the Washington Post and uh
and um
I don't I don't know I can't quite make
it fit with surrender I don't know you
know you're not supposed to surrender to
to illegitimate tyranny obviously ever
any but on the other hand I mean I don't
again I don't know that they changed the
headline all I did was notice that the
original thing that had caught my
attention has a different headline than
the live article which could indicate a
change or it could indicate that the two
things were sourced differently and they
show up with different headlines but if
it is a change in the headline it could
be um to avoid the the negative
connotations of the word policing on the
other hand changing headlines puts blood
in the water and it's a subtle change
yeah so stopped policing oh good stopped
policing like oh no no we don't want you
to encourage the stopping of the
policing right right so but in any case
look I think they could have improved
the title quite a bit the title could
have been something like uh we at the
CIA through our um thinly veiled
journalistic Outlet admit that Brett
Weinstein was right and that zero is
indeed a special number and therefore
and then the subheading could have been
that Elon musk's uh Embrace of free
speech has resulted in a change
cascading through the tech industry that
would have been I think there's a reason
you've never been hired as a headline
writer is that right yeah know I think I
think there are probably a lot of
reasons but um some very good ones
including that you don't seem to to have
the The Knack yeah maybe stick to
rapping well stick to wrapping and
predicting the near future because
that's what has happened here so
actually I want to read a couple
paragraphs into this thing because I I
think it just does reflect the fact that
the model that we presented here zero is
a special number is apparently true and
you can even read about it uh in the
Washington Post so scroll down a little
bit oh jeez I can help can you make that
bigger all right do you want to read it
sure you want me to read just the first
couple first coup paragraphs social
media companies are receding from their
role as Watchdogs against political
misinformation abandoning their most
aggressive efforts to police online
false hoods and a trend expected to
profoundly affect the 2024 presidential
election an array of circumstances is
fueling The Retreat Mass layoffs at meta
and other major tech companies have
gutted teams dedicated to promoting
accurate information
online
right is that what they were doing an
aggressive legal battle over claims that
the Biden Administration pressured
social media platforms to silence
certain speech has blocked a key path to
detecting election interference all
right that's that and then it goes on uh
and ex CEO Elon Musk uh has reset
industry
standards uh it says in a linked fashion
rolling back strict rules against
misinformation on the site formerly
known as Twitter so
anyway people yeah these people to write
it these are presuma I mean maybe
they've offshored this the writing of
this stuff but these people are
presumably Americans who are embracing
the destruction of the First Amendment
here in one of the Premier or formerly
Premier newspapers in the world true the
uh you know so this is madness but it is
a even though they have gone through
incredible contortions um to create a
Russell conjugation that makes good
things like free speech sound dangerous
and terrible they are nonetheless
admitting the point which is that the
game theory means that even a single
econom competitor that Embraces Free
Speech forces that change on everything
else which tells us how to fight it has
told us from the beginning how to fight
that is an amazing acknowledgement it is
a rapid discovery that the pattern
unfolds so quickly that they can't even
separate them in time the rest of the
industry does not want to be left behind
by a platform on which people are still
able to speak freely so good show Elon
well done except for the following thing
here on Twitter well what the social
platform yeah and incidentally I don't
understand how we're supposed to change
our lexicon given that X doesn't
naturally you know you did tweet on X
didn't you so it seems like Twitter is
still alive said that that's the what
you're supposed to say okay so um I'm
I'm sticking with Twitter but here here
we are on Twitter this week we find the
following thing from the uh safety folks
the safety team at Twitter safety team
at Twitter it says X has a
responsibility to put the right systems
in place to ensure our communities have
access to open accurate and safe
political discourse that's why we're
hiring more people updating our policies
and evolving our
product now
that I I don't want to LEAP to
conclusion did you read did you read the
thing it l to uh the blog post yes and
it's it reflects exactly what the Tweet
says but there's a question about what
is going on inside of Twitter on the one
hand Elon was very clear about his
belief in free speech he did say some
stuff that was troubling in fact the
formulation that he used that freedom of
speech is not freedom of reach while it
could have a benign interpretation in
the the sense that no one has an
obligation to
amplify speech that they find negative
in the context of a social media
platform that creates cover for
deboosting and the fact is deboosting is
a violation of the spirit of the First
Amendment the fact is we're supposed to
be able to say whatever it is we think
with very minimal limits the number of
things that you legally cannot do under
that umbrella are tiny so we are
supposed to be able to express any IDE
idea and to the extent that that idea
catches on naturally because people
decide to listen to it decide to
contemplate it decide to discuss it
repeat it whatever they do that's a
natural process and to the extent that
something like Twitter decides to
interfere with that and say well yeah
you can say whatever you want um you
know in a a soundproof room that's not
freedom of speech the fact that you can
utter the words means nothing the fact
that you can utter the words on Twitter
means nothing if Twitter is going to
cryptically interrupt uh the spread of
the thing so anyway we're left with a
puzzle we have somebody who Embraces
free speech that's good and he said some
very clear things about uh he's called
himself a free speech absolutist which
is uh an fairly extreme version of this
um belief but he's also said some things
that have an ambiguous meaning and then
under his on his watch we were watching
the announcement I mean can we go back
to that tweet again how many crazy
euphemistic terms terms are being used
in this one announcement it says X has a
responsibility that's a red flag to put
the right systems another red flag in
place to ensure red flag communities
have access red flag to open red flag
accurate why is open a red flag open
seems like the only the only thing here
that feels right well for the fall I
guess the reason it's a red flag is have
access to
open no I think I I that's that's the
one piece of this phrase I would draw my
red flag on to open accurate right says
who red flag how do they know and safe
red flag political red flag discourse
what was political this is not this
that's not no that's a red flag because
why would you create a category here the
point is is Free Speech means but the
out of what we're talking about and
the fact that you define it as political
or not political is irrelevant we are
free to speak about what we think is
important okay so I think political is
um may be a red flag here only because
of um the fact that the election is
happening we've got the Republican
debate like that we know that this is
this is not cryptically maybe this is
about politics they saying this is about
politics
I I get it on the other hand agreeing
with you oh then I definitely agree with
your
agreement I so there are obviously a
slew of terms in this rather brief uh
assertion that are clearly about some
process that is opaque and
dangerous that said let us steal man and
the position I don't think this could
possibly be defended as a tweet but it
is true that musk and the leadership at
Twitter has to navigate difficult Waters
in the sense that what Twitter what Elon
Musk has said is that within the
confines of the law Twitter will not
interfere with speech which is a very
defensible position the problem is the
laws vary between jurisdictions Germany
has been extremely aggressive in uh
enforcing intolerable limits on what
Germans can read that have cascaded
through Twitter because people who do
not know that they are are not
attempting to speak to Germans in
particular are saying things that
Germany then exerts forces on Twitter
that cause Twitter to not function like
a uh a place where ideas can be freely
exchanged really yes yes this is
markle's government oh yeah yes and so
there's a European context there's a
German a specifically German context and
all of and you know let's let's give the
man is Du he has a difficult job
figuring out how to navigate a world in
which lots of people are experimenting
with intolerable limits on speech and
Germany has always been this way Germany
has always since World War II had limits
on uh things like um the depictions of
Nazi symbols and you can understand why
Germany would have leaned that way but
it also does things like creates uh a
problem you know when Roger Waters
depicts Nazis and dresses up like a Nazi
as he's doing a a concert in which the
wall is being presented the fact that
he's been doing that on stage for
decades and that he's not embracing
Nazism is irrelevant because he's doing
things that that according to the
Germans formally violate their policies
so anyway yeah musk has a difficult
problem and there's a question musk is
simultaneously running a business he
cannot well I don't I won't say cannot
he could uh subordinate the business's
Financial well-being to uh its
importance as a platform and he could
just simply say we will here are the
rules here's how Free Speech applies on
the platform and uh what other you know
countries can ban Twitter and then they
will have to deal with their own
populations uh who will be angry that
suddenly Twitter is not available are
you arguing that you think this is a
response to things like uh German law
I'm not I'm steel Manning what the best
possible explanation for that absolutely
orwellian tweet is that they are trying
to juggle a difficult set of constraints
that are impossible to properly
reconcile that they are and I mean
someone with a with a different mindset
might also read that tweet if you would
put it up against Zach I've never SE
seen it until just now uh the second
part of it says that they're going to be
hiring more people um and there it has
certainly been widely discussed that the
mass layoffs that happened when musk
took over Twitter uh was about firing
precisely people who were doing this
sort of job right right who were who
were putting ghosts in the machine who
were shadowbanning people who were
effectively censoring content and and
restricting reach of people who um you
know engaged in wrong think and wrong
speak and you know what what is this who
are these people who are going to be
hired if not um you know one toone
replacements for exactly those people
who were fired right I mean another way
to put it would be um how many people
does it take not to censor speech my
thinking is you could do that with very
few people um so you
know that's where we are again I I want
to leave room look my my advice to you
Elon if you're going to engage in some
sort of needle threading with respect to
other jurisdictions that have onerous
restrictions on
speech you need to give us a wink so
that we know that you are not backing
off the commitment that you very clearly
expressed to free speech as understood
in an American
context right this is an American
company and uh we understood you to be
very clear that you were creating a
Public Square in which uh other than the
restrictions that come from actually
illegal content we were going to be free
to exchange ideas there's obviously a
question about things that aren't ideas
things like doxing there's a question
about things like pornography but with
respect to ideas there ought be nothing
that we cannot talk about on this
platform and to the extent that that's
not going to be uh the nature of the
place going forward we need such a place
and why do we need such a place you can
read it in the Washington Post of all
locations this week you can discover
that what you did actually had exactly
the impact that you claimed you wanted
and for you to back off it now would be
a terrible misstep in my opinion so
please Elon send us a sign let us know
that you're still committed to this and
help us understand uh what the
constraints are that you have to deal
with internationally if that's in fact
what's driving it because otherwise what
it seems like is that uh ing Yaro was an
indication of where Twitter is headed
and um that's not a good
sign uh I guess uh given this is new new
to me right now um and I have not read
the article that you showed the
Washington Post article I wondered to
what degree you're compelled by its
argument uh it it says excuse
me uh we had such a lovely rainstorm for
two days and all the smoke is gone but
feel like there's residual like pollen
stuck places yes I've uh retained a bit
of the smoke I'm getting rid of it
slowly um but you know it what what just
the little that you showed us of that
article suggested that Facebook again
I'm going to continue to call it
Facebook meta at least is a name unlike
X but uh still Facebook and YouTube it
argues uh have basically followed suit
have waited for uh you know the fact
that zero is a special number uh to uh
to the the the zeron of it all to change
Twitter led the way Twitter is now the
one and now Facebook and YouTube that
article would appear to argue um are
similarly backing off of their mistis
and malformation policies I'm not
familiar with Facebooks really at all um
but certainly we uh we have been the
direct uh targets of YouTube's uh
policies and I don't I I I just I guess
I wonder if it's true and I'm not saying
I don't I don't I don't even have I
don't think think a guess as to whether
or not it might be um because it it
seems like yeah zero is a special number
it might well have followed they Twitter
may have basically opened the gates for
this um but also 2020 didn't go so well
for any any of them right yeah uh and
you know no matter what they did they
got grief from both sides and uh you
know basically saying you know what okay
no policy then and yes we're going to
get grief from the people who want us to
you want to do things but at least if we
don't have our fingerprints on it at all
you can't tell us we were managing it
wrong because we have said we refuse to
manage so I think you're you're opening
a very interesting set of questions it's
possible that the that that article has
a purpose and it's not an admission
because what it is is a an intemp an
attempt to induce the other platforms to
double down on restrictions rather than
follow musk in other words that
functions as an accusation that they are
following suit which might cause them to
uh to um to protest and provide evidence
that's not true right uh it's also the
case that we have legal precedent uh
where the executive branch was caught
red-handed dictating and the courts have
now said this is intolerable so there is
a formal restriction on what can happen
so um how that all plays out I don't
know but I I do think whether what can
happen from the executive branch I mean
just as has happened in actual politics
so you know there will be end runs
created you know there'll be lobbyists
and packs and you know whatever be yeah
yeah there will be there will be an arms
race about how many removes is far
enough that it becomes legal and I will
say that there is legal precedent
arguing that it would have to be
incredibly
remote um so there are at least two
important precedents in which private
entity
have been declared effectively public um
and you know so courts have said look
you have to abide by the First Amendment
because you're functioning in a
governmental fashion yep uh so anyway
the it's an interesting set of questions
but I don't think it I almost don't
think it matters because what is
contained in the article whether it is
designed to push people in a direction
or it is an acknowledgment that they
have been pushed in that direction still
the underlying thing that is true is the
game theory below which means that a
people like musk have to be very careful
what they do because the Cascade I think
musk understands this very well the
cascading implications of what they do
are much larger than the platforms that
they uh that they actually control right
um which means they have to be careful
in both
directions because this is a one way the
game theory Works in One Direction the
lagging partner destroys their own
business the leading partner with
respect to something like speech gets
the advantage of being there first so if
if you are the if you're pulling in the
direction of restrictive speech then
you're only going to have fools on your
platform because who wants to have their
own speech restricted you what you're
going to have is people moving towards
the platform where they're free to say
the most things that they're interested
in
saying so uh it is very important that
musk not blink because he's in the lead
and the fact is he could lose the
advantage the competitive advantage that
comes from being first in this direction
if he uh if he takes his foot off the
gas and meta catches up and they're both
restrictive zones um but meta has seen
is slightly more free for example that
would be a disaster for Not only would
it be a disaster for Free Speech but it
would be a disaster for Twitter and musk
because it would mean that his uh
utilization of an actually free platform
in order to recover his investment would
be uh would be stifled by uh his
competitors catching up so so
that I'm way out of my depth here but
that that argument seems to work only
for
equivalently
megalithic companies so we're talking
about Twitter YouTube Facebook obviously
there is an actual Free Speech platform
uh that is a direct competitor for at
least one of those right like so you
know we are we are on Rumble now we're
also um on YouTube but uh YouTube has
treated us extraordinarily badly and it
is understood at this point to have been
um you know actively censoring and
shadowbanning and and demonetizing not
just us but many other people as well
throughout uh throughout Co and and and
before um we we we we were the Direct
Hit of it in you know beginning in 2021
and nothing has changed um but you know
Rumble and locals uh which are now a a
unit
um is actively specifically explicitly a
free speech platform and is vying um to
be uh uh you know a competitor uh worthy
of sharing the same stage with YouTube
and it's an excellent product but it
just doesn't have the market share yet
so um so it's so what what you were
talking about only works like you you
you were talking about like different
weight classes yeah it and it is a
weight class issue and the reason that
that weight class issue applies here has
to do with network effects the fact is
YouTube has behaved
abominably and that's not a secret and
the number of us who have recognized it
who have suffered from it uh is huge so
that raises the question why don't we
just simply YouTube somewhere else and
many people are doing that but the
problem is that the audience who is not
Towing the line of what is or Towing the
line is the wrong term but is not up
against the boundary of what YouTube
tolerates just because it's not what
they talk about right right because for
whatever reason Their audience isn't
large enough or their interests aren't
controversial or whatever it is that
audience is still benefiting from the
legacy of YouTube being the only player
on the Block and so for example let's
say still got orders of magnitude more
influence because it has the because has
the people right and in some sense let's
take an example of something that isn't
controversial that YouTube has done
brilliantly that causes it to be very
hard to turn off the lights at the
place which is what we should
do the the uh catalog of howto videos on
YouTube is staggeringly deep if you want
to figure out how to wire a light
circuit with control from two points I
guarantee that you'll find 25 videos
there explaining how to do it you'll
find somebody who speaks in a way that
you can absolutely understand it and you
can talk yourself through doing it even
if you've never done anything like that
before y that's a very powerful thing
there is no reason that couldn't live on
Rumble it could live on Rumble but the
problem is how do you get what already
exists in that library to move and this
is the same thing that's protecting
Wikipedia no and and you know with I
haven't ever looked for that um but when
you go looking for like I just need to
figure out you know how do I do X in
this piece of software and you know
sometimes you may just go to go to
Google and look for look for the message
boards but um sometimes you're looking
for videos and you benefit from a depth
of the
library excuse me um you're not you're
not going to go to the platform that
only has two videos if you could go to
the one that has 30 and you can choose
among them yeah so what that explains is
why there's a two-tiered system why
Rumble isn't immediately in a position
to do to YouTube what musk is trying to
do to it um and that is because it
starts with a disadvantage that is not
its own from size and so there is a very
powerful argument why should you be on
Rumble and not YouTube because Rumble
will protect your speech rights and that
matters more than anything um that's a
great argument and then there is the
inertia argument that has us still
visiting YouTube grudgingly to figure
out how to do X Y and Z still has us
going to Wikipedia to find out you know
how deep uh you know like Victoria is
right um so those th that
Legacy uh that keeps those platforms a
float also sets the boundaries of who is
in a position to drive the game theory
now Rumble is doing a very good job of
marshalling its primary competitive
Advantage into actually putting itself
in a position to to uh Dethrone YouTube
and YouTube uh ought to be paying really
close attention because it could end up
becoming
Myspace which uh you know would Delight
many of us so um these things are coming
and the next year is going to be
fascinating because the battle over
speech matters a great deal in the runup
to the next US presidential election
indeed all right
um that's it for there yep for then do
you have a musical intro and do I need
to beat bucks in order to I'd like you
do you have a
violin uh I have a very small violin
which I break out on occasions when
people have do you need
rosin uh yes I believe the bow has been
recently rosined but I would have to
check carefully of course she would yeah
um
okay uh Chris rufo Chris chher rufo has
published a couple of pieces a number of
pieces in City Journal and I want to
share some from his most recent one and
uh from an earlier one and then talk a
bit about uh some of the implications
there there in so God there's something
in this air that is not that is not air
that is not that I'm not happy with um
okay here we go this is this is the
piece and you can put this up uh that
rufo published uh this week August 24th
2023 in City Journal a piece called
barbarism in the name of equality an
austin-based doctor performs nonbinary
genital surgeries and I'm just going to
share a bit of uh a bit of the piece in
2015 uh crane a doctor an
MD uh received a flurry of publicity as
an innovator in I don't even know how to
pronounce that word vaginoplasty I guess
vaginoplasty don't know yes the uh
creation of a so-called artificial
vagina
um in 2015 crane received a flurry of
publicity as an innovator of
vaginoplasty which involves castrating
and creating an artificial vagina for
male to female patients and phalloplasty
which involves creating and installing
an artificial penis for female to male
patients he boasted of a 1 to twoyear
weight list and claimed to have one of
the highest volumes of transgender
surgeries in the United
States since then business has boomed
crane operates clinics in San Francisco
California and Austin
Texas
San Francisco and Austin wild employs a
team of five doctors and conducts
procedures on more than 1,000 patients
per year as part of this case load his
practice has veered into the disturbing
new territory of non-binary surgery
which includes castration unic and
nullification procedures which crane
describes as the process of quote
removing all external genitalia to
create a smooth transition from the
abdomen to the
groin end quot crane is also designed to
performed hundreds of non-binary
surgeries in which he fashion together
both male and female genitalia for a
single individual
that is he creates an artificial penis
for a woman while retaining her vagina
or creates an artificial vagina for a
man while retaining his
penis crane recounted the story of
performing his first non-binary genital
surgery in a question and answer session
for potential patients quote in the
beginning of my practice within the
first year I'd say I had a trans man
come to me and he wanted a phalloplasty
but he wanted to keep his vagina his
vagina crane recall after a process of
soul searching he concluded that if
gender was not binary his surgeries did
not need to conform to a typical male
female pattern quote the patient wanted
to keep his vagina because he got sexual
gratification out of having a vagina and
I thought it's kind of ass salt to make
a patient remov an organ that they're
enjoying let's keep
it I have written um fairly extensively
about um all of this but um in so far as
we have been um uh very patient with and
uh even including of what we have called
in the past true trans people uh a
category I am increasingly suspicious of
but let's put that aside it has always
been abundantly clear to me uh that
non-binary is an affectation and a
delusion and a fantasy and has no
relationship to reality
and
um this guy so he's making both people
with supposedly both both sets of
genitals and of course he's not because
you can't actually make a penis out of
the skin from the forearm or a vagina by
inverting tissue uh you you just you
can't right um but he's also doing this
other thing he's turning them into
Barbies and Kens right he's making what
does it say um
removing all external genitalia to
create a smooth transition from the
abdomen to the
groin how how does how does this doctor
have a license like how is he like what
will it take what will it take for
everyone to start seeing the atrocities
that are happening and in the name of
what it's not so this isn't this isn't
Nazi doctors pretending to do this in
the name of science and medicine this
is this is pretending that this is good
for people because it's kind of an
assault to make a patient remove an
organ that they're enjoying and we're
just going to add whatever they feel
like
yeah it's it's a couple of different
things I would call it evidence-free
medicine
and that's really good yeah um yeah yes
and yes you would so will I from now on
what I what I mean
is these tricks that the sophists
sophists are using to get people to back
off of actual logic are so powerful that
there is essentially no argument that
they cannot protect the our inability to
agree on anything at all anymore that we
can agree that 2 plus 2 equals 4 that um
men can't become women that pedophilia
is bad all the things that every
reasonable person used to agree on fact
that we can't agree on those things is
evidence that the power contained in
these threatening arguments is so great
that what you would expect to happen if
some doctor made this argument in any
era in which anything functioned then
you would find the
uh medical societies the journals would
come down on that doctor like a ton of
bricks and the clear burden would be on
the doctor to prove that what they were
doing was tolerable enough that it
should not cause them to be um thrown
out of the profession and into prison
and into prison right the fact that
that's not even happening here and
they're just like oh well that's nice
he's he's making non-binary surgeries
he's pruning
genitalia off of perfectly healthy
people I guess that's how I guess that's
the conclusion medicines come to no it
hasn't what's happened is the threat of
being accused of transphobia is so great
that a doctor who wishes to innovate new
UN previously unthought modes of
Mutilation that that doctor can simply
do it because what are you going to do
say that doesn't make any sense you're
mutilating people that would make you a
transphobe which is of course the worst
thing a person can be yeah right that's
where we are so it is these surgeries
are postmodern in the most obvious sense
they are utopian and I mean that in the
sense that patients are being misled
into oh yes we can do that for you no
you can't you can do
something but the idea that you are
actually giving a person the equipment
that they weren't born with you simply
are not nor is it conceivable that you
could and the evidence that that's true
is obvious and even the medical
societies and medical schools can't
manage to muster enough courage to point
this out because the threat of this
argument in public is so great that
nothing can withstand facing it down so
um we're getting there so there's
there's a couple of quotes in the future
here that um Direct irly relate to that
so I'm not going to respond to that
until I get until we we get there um
just one more short um excerpt from this
piece from rufo this week about this
doctor who is um creating Barbie and
kendalls and people with two sets of
genitalia as well supposedly crane the
doctor proposed two solutions first the
social utopian solution to re-educate
all of society to accept that biological
sex is not binary quote XX is not always
female and XY not always male and quote
humanize this predicament with the end
goal of acceptance of anti-normative
sexual
identity second the technical
constructivist solution to remove alter
fabricate and reorganize human gellia so
that transgender patients can quote
become the people they were always meant
to
be and
um yeah so maybe I should just go right
to the the the previous piece uh where
rofo was interviewing an excellent
doctor who sees this for what it is um
but maybe before I do uh I will say you
know
a many of the people who are arguing um
in favor of the mutilation of children
um have have caught on on to the fact
that that many of their Straw Men
positions are laughable and apparently
this guy hasn't you know it's not about
the chromosomes it's never been about
the chromosomes uh in mammals uh we have
we are uh we have what is called genetic
sex determination which really means
chromosomal sex determination which
means that in almost every single case
in almost every single mammal with a
couple of species exceptions at the base
of the mammal tree that is the aidas and
the duck Bell platypus we have uh two um
sex chromosomes x's and y's and females
are XX and males are XY um but those
things are what determine what sex you
are they aren't what sex sex you are uh
what sex you are is about what gamits
you produce and um the sophists have all
sorts of ludicrous responses here about
well okay so I've got a developmental uh
disability which says uh you know a
disorder that says that even though I
produce eggs I should have been
producing sperm therefore I'm actually
male um so you know these people aren't
serious um they think they're serious
but they're not and they should really
you know get outside and do something
real and stop destroying children um
but um it's not about the
chromosomes um but the idea that in the
words of this doctor transgender
patients need to be able to remove alter
fabricate and reorganize human Galia so
that they can become the people they
were always meant to
be this is and I am not by any means the
first person to point this out but um
increasingly I think this is one of the
main arguments we should be making what
you are doing is telling people that
they are broken and that
uh they are not anything like what they
should be they should not accept
themselves as they are uh you you should
not accept them as they are either you
should celebrate the fact that they
cannot accept themselves as they are
they should certainly not strive within
themselves to make themselves better uh
what they need is you know techno
utopian intervention uh that will surely
destroy them and make them and guarantee
their misery for the rest of their lives
while holding them in sway to the
pharmaceutical companies uh which
doesn't sound like uh a wonderful future
to me no and it raises this is a a point
you and I have each made
but if we accept that the mind and the
body of these people is in Conflict it
is in no way obvious and it is certainly
not in keeping with any ancient version
of trans that the right approach should
be to modify the body for the one for
one thing the body is a complex system
about which we know very little and have
even less power yeah the ability to to
create biologically is minimal
so the best we could do is simulate
whereas we could change your mind and in
fact the mind is built to repair itself
and most people with dysphoria find that
if you know in childhood if they have
dysphoria and nothing is done
they grow out of it right so the point
is the mind is is a is a marvelous
healing organ and also some amount of
the dysphoria isn't dysphoria it's it's
imaginative play yep it's considering
what other possibilities there are and
you know what when you're told as a
child that you actually can't become a
steam train or a rhinoceros maybe you're
devastated but for sake get over
it and if you're told you can't become a
girl or a boy because you were born the
other thing again this is part of what
being a human is and growing up and
engaging your imaginative play cool
don't bring the doctors into it
definitely don't bring the
endocrinologists and the surgeons into
it yes and don't blame society for
restricting what you can do because the
fact is you live in a society that has
never there has never been its equal
with respect to how free you are to uh
you know to subscribe to whatever gender
roles you prefer right right nobody is
telling you you have to live one way or
the other you have to go back to 1950 or
anything anything like this so the fact
is the getting over it what animal would
you like to be an otter okay you can't
be damn that does suck but learning that
it sucks and there's nothing I can do
about it and so I guess I'm going to
have to you know live as a a close
relative of chimps well that's weird
every day I swear it is but uh I am over
it I'm an adult and it does not not the
most beautiful C no it's a terrible
Choice even Gibbons would have been a
much better one but yeah but no we had
we had to go we CH that's uh that's
God's Little joke on us I guess but um
but anyway the point is okay so we're
chimp
relatives that is a strange sort of it's
a interesting hybrid between advantages
and disadvantages but nonetheless wisdom
is understanding that that's what you're
stuck with and going with it so and we
lost our opposable toes I mean come on I
know where they are they're just well
there I mean we got by pedality but I
don't know uh selection opposed them and
now they're they opposed toes is what
they are something something all right
that was a pointless detour but but the
point is the getting over it is a
developmental process and these people
are all as we called our episode last
week deal deal with the accept the hands
your deal play play the cards play the
cards your de what called it so the yeah
the idea that proper development
involves reconciling yourself to those
cards and you know believe me there are
a lot worse cards than uh wishing you
had been the other sex there's profound
disabilities that people are born with
that they then strive and overcome uh
this this is just one of the ways in
which a adult mind has to reconcile
itself to the realities of the physics
that we are constrained by the biology
the era that you're born into all of
those things and that
um I think there's something interesting
in the idea that these people both want
to block physical puberty and block
mental maturation and it really is a
matter of uh you know a tantrum about
things that you might want but aren't
supposed to be on the
table well I don't know I I'm not sure I
agree with that last thing because I
don't it's not the the children um and
it is you know the children who decide
they want this thing um maybe being
allowed to have a tantrum but it's only
on the menu because of the adults this
like the idea that you could engage in
endocrinological and surgical
malfeasance against children uh was not
the children's idea oh it that's they
they're not the ones I'm accusing of
having a tantrum it's the uh the
movement that has decided that Society
has to be turned upside down over this
issue and that the correct intervention
is Surgical and uh
hormonal um and that anybody who stand
who disagrees with those claims is in
fact morally
defective okay so uh rufo wrote um in
June of this year uh uh reported on a
dialogue with a physician who he says
works on a a major Children's Hospital
in a blue City he's anonymous here the
piece is called thrown to the wolves and
I of course link these in the show notes
rufo Begins by asking please Begin by
sitting the scene what is it like in a
major Children's Hospital in the United
States regarding transgender
interventions for
children physician I think the best way
to answer that question is to talk about
the cultural shift that happened in 2020
because transgender ideology and Co are
inextricably
linked normally doctors operate by the
authority of the professional societies
that govern our specific practice I that
worked because the individuals in those
institutions were reliable intelligent
and thoughtful but with Co in 2020 we
started getting medical decrees without
medical decree decrees without peer
review or evidence you saw this with
masks social distancing and emergency
use
authorizations these decrees were
expressed as something that everyone had
to do without justification based on
sound science the other thing was
censorship if you were to ask questions
or Express doubt about these medical
decrees you would be ostracized within
your department and used to a good
chance of being publicly humiliated
severely reprimanded or
fired that's when transgender ideology
really took off Within These academic
institutions so-called experts in the
field of transgender medicine would
simply declare that Purity blockers and
other interventions were the gold
standard of care the evidence to support
this is completely fraudulent but no
descent was permitted everyone within
the medical community knew that if he
questioned transgender ideology he would
suffer the same type of repercussions
that had happened during coid the best
way to describe the environment would be
as an authoritarian censorious culture
that discourages any meaningful debate
and encourages the demonization of
anyone who asks
questions I think this is incredibly apt
I would not have put uh the rise in
transgender ideology uh as concomittant
with coid because we of course were
seeing it um before then but it may well
be that it took off and that we we we
don't know and you know this is a doctor
inside the system um that it took off
and became
uh precisely that doctors were even less
likely doctors and nurses and all the
other Healthcare professionals were even
less likely to raise a finger and say
well you are we sure like are are are we
sure even just the are we sure even just
the like can I tap the brakes a little
bit on this uh May well have U more or
less
disappeared as we saw the incredible
social pressure that indeed um went way
past um you know shaming people and Def
firing people and to you know in into
totally diabolical treatment uh with
regard to um the the coid the mainstream
take on coid most of which was
completely batshit crazy uh and the
mainstream um at least according to wo
and New York Times and NPR and such uh
take on on trans at this point which is
again completely batshit crazy so I
absolutely agree uh I would not have put
these two things in parallel but having
heard that right description it has the
Ring Of Truth and it actually maps on to
something which I've been I've been
trying to get others
to to uh embrace the formulation and so
far people uh I think they get it but
they haven't seen how significant it is
which is the coup of Public Health
against medicine yes most people don't
see these things as distinct but public
health is population level medicine and
there's an argument for it because if
you optimize for individual health you
may end up with a suboptimal outcome for
the population which is the ostensible
justification for thinking at a
population level on the other hand the
problem is that the way medicine is
supposed to function remember doctors
are supposed to be
scientists you have a a a scientific
degree and a history in which doctors
discovered what worked pulled their
information and a understanding you you
know it was a a therapeutic science but
it was a science nonetheless what
happens when and you would imagine if
Pharma was driving it doesn't very well
want if it wants to sell you stuff
that's high profit and dubious efficacy
and dubious safety it doesn't very well
want doctors around the water cooler to
say you know what I tried that drug it
didn't work any near anywhere near as
well as the one that we already had and
what's more I saw the following effects
and somebody else might say yeah I've
seen that too and what's more etc etc
doctors pulling their information from a
groundup
decentralized emergent knowledge base
that's medicine public health is an
excuse for imposing from the top down an
interpretation and then using coercion
to prevent people from departing from it
which is what happened well two things I
think um trans ideology and um SARS KOB
2 are fundamentally different obviously
with regard to uh their potential to um
have implications broadly across the
population now trans ideology in fact is
but it's one individual at a time right
and their social contagion and all of
this is true but um if if what we were
being told about SARS CO2 and it's both
its High um case fatality rate and its
High
um um transmissibility um were were true
uh than uh the public health apparatus
that was arguing for uh for
interventions that were functional not
the interventions that they actually put
into place which were not functional but
interventions that actually stop the
spread of a highly infectious and highly
deadly disease um are the purview of
Public Health that is that is what
public health is supposed to be doing
right and uh and trans
is contagious at the social level but
it's not it's not contagious in the same
way so you can't make an AR an argument
in the same way that that that you could
um potentially for for a virus if all of
these other things were true which which
it turns out they weren't um but it's
also you know I think
Pharma um is in a very different role
when it is trying to get people to take
statins and when it's trying to get
people to take vaccines because its role
in in cre stattin which um you know are
dangerous and almost always not a good
idea um is at the individual level you
aren't you you never are going to argue
that you need to take a Statin to
protect your neighbor whereas the
vaccine argument from the very beginning
of vaccines has been in part one of
things like hert immunity like everyone
we need more people to get these things
so that the people who can't can be
protected that sort of thing I'm not
making the point you think I'm making
okay um my point is there is in theory
something to be done at the level of
Public Health there are problems that
are created by treating every patient as
an individual now I am less and less
convinced that Society ever has the
right to prioritize
populations and to harm the individual
in that process in fact I would never
have said they had the right to harm the
individual there are risks that that
come along with this having seen what
we've seen I'm not convinced that the
argument for Public Public Health to me
is an academic science turning it into a
therapeutic approach is problematic for
all of the reasons that we saw during
coid but my central point here is if you
were Pharma then you would want Public
Health emphasized over medicine you
would want it to displace medicine
because medicine will prevent you from
selling bad drugs because doctors who
administer them will notice the effects
and they will prefer the stuff that
works because because they are faced
with the patient so Public Health but
hold on public
health provides an excuse for overriding
medicine which is what the corrupting
influence of Pharma inherently wants to
do and what that means is that having
carved out that territory hey there is a
scientific realm that allows us to
override doctors is what trans ideology
is now parasitizing okay so you're
you're saying it it's a way from
for Pharma to get in the door and then
override doctors even in places for
public health has no role at all there's
no there's no reason the public health
should have an opinion about stattin I
think and I maybe that's a silly example
to be using because I think that that
drug is insane but you know so well
actually so let's pick one that seems
like it should have no Public Health
consequences but actually um hey once
again it's probably the opposite of what
uh of what you might think uh um aspirin
let's put aside the nids let's put aside
the Tylenol let's take the you know the
drug that has been on the market for
longest and um except in somewhat rare
cases we think is relatively safe right
for
adults um but people take aspin to
reduce fever and fever is very often an
Adaptive response and so if part of what
doctors are doing but also public health
is doing is just trying to make you more
comfortable and oh you poor dear you're
experiencing these symptoms that you
don't like here let's get rid of the
symptoms what that's going to do very
often is send you out into the world as
a less symptomatic infectious person U
more likely to get people sick so Public
Health should actually be campaigning
against symptom reducers in in
infectious diseases but public health is
doing nothing of the sort right that
that is exactly the correct analysis so
public health is a set of
arguments in isolation from any advice
about how we should deal with anything
it is a set of arguments that are
important to understand it becomes an
excuse to uh coers medicine and once
you've carved out that excuse then
everything utilizes it and so I I would
point out how did Public Health get
involved in the coercion of people into
getting a shot that turned out did not
block transmission because transmission
is the entire reason that this is a
public health question even Theory it
was called a vaccine well it was called
a vaccine that's one way and the other
way is the whole flatten the curve
argument the idea of overwhelming
hospitals which takes an individual
level question and again makes it into a
population level question and so look
Pharma Pharma is aware of where all of
the trigger points are in the structure
of academic and medical science there is
one such trigger for example where gez
if you were going to sell dangerous
you wouldn't want a control group
because that control group is ultimately
going to prove how dangerous the
you sold them was so how do you get rid
of the control group ah there's an
ethical principle that if a drug is so
effective at treating a condition uh
that uh you know it reaches above some
threshold then it would be immoral not
to vaccinate the control group or to to
administer it to the control group huh
that's a Target they're going to have to
hit every goddamn time they can't afford
to have a control group aren't they and
so the point is well gentlemen get to
work we need to figure out how to
Marshall enough power that we can always
hit that trigger so the control group
always magically disappears and my point
is the public health trigger is another
such thing we always have to figure out
why there's a public health argument for
why we get to tell doctors what to do
when ordinarily doctors would be
discussing with each other what they
should do and so I'm going to claim that
the idea of standard of care is it's a
code word for top down
top down medicine and that's what
they've done is they've displaced
doctors who would otherwise figure out
what to do painfully and with a whole
lot of loss of life but yes doctors
would figure out what to do and they
would get better at doctoring not worse
how do you prevent that from happening
you mandate top down how do you get to
top down public health and so the idea
that trans is riding on that carrier
wave it's it's a parasite yes um and it
is taking advantage of the fact that
something has carved out the ability to
tell doctors what they have to think
that's what's going on but obviously
it's a huge bone uh to Pharma as well oh
yeah I mean it it creates uh perennial
patience of anyone who starts down this
this train and um and you just you know
you're you're a your a client your
customer a farmer for the rest of your
life once you start yeah so they're
mutualists
actually uh
yeah so um couple more couple more
quotes from this roof article from Jun
June
2023 uh he asks this excellent Anonymous
physician uh what is going on with um
the tenets of transgender medical Theory
and how they have changed Medical
Practice the doctor says could you show
my screen here um but in reality when
you affirm these individuals gender
identity what you are doing is affirming
their hatred for themselves you have
these children who are going through
confusing times difficult times when you
affirm this belief system what you are
really doing is telling them you hate
yourself at this moment and I will
affirm that we have to ask ourselves why
do these people have such high rates of
suicide because we're affirming that
they should hate themselves and that
they should try to destroy
themselves so that's extraordinary and
uh one last thing from which I want to
come back to at the end of this
conversation but
um the very last long extended quotation
from our physician here again please
keep my screen up um
one of the the the physician writes one
of the things I've been thinking about
is what puberty blockers do to
children this medication is called a
gonadotropin releasing hormone Agonist
and it comes in the form of monthly
injections or an implant and because it
simulates the activity of this hormone
it shuts down the activity of the
hypothalamus the hypothalamus is this
almond siiz structure in your brain it's
one of the most Primal structures we
have and it controls all the other
hormonal structures in your body your
sexual development your emotions your
fight ORF flight response everything
but it shouldn't be described in such
cold physiological terms because your
hypothalamus is not just a hormone
Factory it's the system that allows you
to stand in awe of the beauty of a
sunset or to hear the sounds of
orchestral music and to stop whatever
you're doing and want to listen and I
always think that if someone were to ask
me where is it that you would look for
the Divine spark in each individual I
would say that it would be somewhere
beneath the inner chamber which is the
Greek derivation of the term
hypothalamus to shut down that system is
to shut down what makes us
human wow
yeah wow so
um it got me thinking again about the
hypothalamus um
and well one of the things I did I just
went the very last quarter that I was a
professor um that I was teaching was
fall 2016 because I was on sabatical the
next two uh quarters and then I think um
did you invite a of students to your
classroom May 23rd of 2017 or did they
just show up it's hard to remember so
long ago um but anyway the last time I
was in the classroom fulltime was fall
of 2016 and I was teaching a full-time
program in vertebrate
Evolution um I'm part of part of the
program included a comparative anatomy
lab we were dissecting um sharks and
cats and then with regard to neuro um uh
we did shark brain dissections and and
sheep brains and I we just went back and
looked at my um my notes on on um from
the from the neural lab um that I that I
gave to the
students uh and included in it is uh
just my here little definition of uh the
hypothalamus and you can show this if
you want the hypothalamus has diverse
roles including homeostasis it organizes
endocrine especially pituitary and
autonomic functions controls motivation
relating to temperature regulation
hunger and thirst and regulates
emotional and reproductive Behavior it's
gigantic right it's doing it's doing all
of these things and um you know their
the brain is is is complex and the
hypothalamus is part of the D Dylon
which is the second of the five primary
parts of the brain uh it's part of the
forbrain um it's it's part of the brain
that is uh expanded um specifically in
Birds but um but also to some degree in
mammals and and boy do we boy do we need
it
um go on well I was just going to point
out that in one way that list is a
mindblowing collection of important
things it is also it implies something
because we're not talking about a huge
structure we're talking we are talking
about a it's not tiny but it's small a
set of black boxes that are connected
through this mechanism which nobody can
yet understand we are a long way from
having any sort of detailed
understanding of how this thing
integrates these things we can just sort
of list if you destroy the hypothalamus
I don't know if you can survive that but
um but nonetheless if it is damaged here
are some things that we see uh are
impacted by it so the point is it is an
integrator of fundamental things I mean
in that list is
motivation so you telling me that you
feel comfortable
disrupting something that is in some way
we cannot specify involved in motivation
isn't motivation underlying exactly as
that doctor was arguing the most
fundamental things about being human
what what you will choose to do with
your precious time on Earth
yeah so so it's a welcome to complex
systems uh moment exactly um so let me
just
uh I wasn't going to share this exactly
but I think maybe I will um gonna let me
see I think that's the part I want to um
share maybe Zach you can wow that did
not work at all that's terrible you can
show my so hold on just a second SEC
don't don't do it yet um yeah here we go
so this is um from the National Library
of Medicine um it is related to NIH but
um it's a place you can go um for a
scholarly like you have to understand
some of the language but um a relatively
robust it's sort of an encyclopedia
encyclopedic uh place for the current
thinking of various things medical and
uh uh and even some some things that
don't necessarily have obvious medical
implications um but so this is about
gonadotropin releasing hormone analoges
gatr and releasing hormone being
something that is produced um at the
level of the hypothalamus and it in it
in turn produces releases um leutinizing
hormone and follicle stimulating hormone
uh which in turn promote a Cascade of
the various sex steroid hormones which
are androgens in in males testosterone
and andren and such and estrogens in
females uh so it's you know it's at the
top or at least high up in a a Cascade
um that affects lots and lots of systems
so um background on so the analoges um
are going to be oh we've figured out
things that can actually do the kind of
work of ganat trop and releasing hormone
cool cool isn't that also what could
possibly go wrong welcome to complex
systems uh well here if I try to make
this bigger unfortunately my whole
screen goes wonky so I'm going just have
to read it this small font uh
gonadotropin releasing hormone is a
decapeptide doesn't matter that is
produced on the hypothalamus and acts
upon ganat tropin releasing hormone
receptors on the surface of ganat tropen
cells in the pituitary gland stimulating
the release of lutenizing hormone and
folicular stimulating hormone which in
turn stimulate the production and
release of testosterone by the male
testes and by the female ovaries of
placenta as I just
said gonadotropin releasing hormone is
typically produced in a pulsatile manner
and its synthesis is regulated by
circulating levels of testosterone in
men and estrogens in women infusions of
ganat tropin releasing hormone agonists
that is things that enhance the
production as opposed to antagonists
that inhibit the production so uh
infusions of GNR agonists produce an
initial transient increase in sex
hormones but with continued
non-pulsatile
stimulation both lutenizing hormone and
follicule stimulating hormone synthesis
are inhibited and estrogen and
testosterone levels decline so G&R
analoges and you can give me my screen
back here um are uh
used um they are they're dangerous uh
they're used primarily uh for um
treatment of prostate cancer
and they are increasingly used off label
as puberty blockers for people who
present as trans so the most famous one
the one that people are likely to hear
have heard of if they've heard of any of
them is Lupron um that's the that's the
trade name um but there are many others
and um I guess I wonder if you want to
tell like when I when I first was
thinking on this you know this we are
familiar with this at some level right
like I'm and I used to teach gross
anatomy and you know there but but we're
not endocrinologists and um and while
luteinizing hormone and FSH follicle
stimulating hormone are you know part of
you know a background of training in in
biology it's not our our first language
um and the idea that you could either
use a um a G&R Agonist or an
antagonist to block puberty and both of
those types of things are used to block
puberty which is again not safe not
recommended you should never ever do it
um but is fascinating and it seems at
first like why would that possibly work
like how is it you wouldn't you just
want to block it use an antagonist block
it and be done with it um if that's
really what you want to do which again
you shouldn't uh why does an Agonist
work at all why does giving the body
more of the thing help to ultimately and
in not too long a period of time um stop
the production of that thing in the body
entirely um and we have we have a
unrelated but kind of comparable
indological story from a beautiful
former epic Tabby of ours yeah we had a
a lovely cat he was a sweetest sweetest
cat I think we've ever had um uh named
abomi and he had uh he had extra digits
and he stood like he had little mittens
on was very very cute very sweet animal
um anyway he uh had multiple run-ins
with death the law he was the law yes
but he was also rescued by veterinary
science more than once and one of those
cases uh you are on topic but I would
just say that U when I I joke that he
had multiple ARs with the law he
actually at one point had managed to con
a uh an elderly neighbor of ours that he
was despite being obviously well taken
care of and uh and and and well-loved uh
had conter into believing that he was
homeless and so she started putting food
out for him so he started to gain weight
on our watch like what is happening and
uh at the point that we finally got him
to keep a caller on himself for a while
she showed up at our door I think and
was like but but he's my cat like no
he's 12 and he's been ours for a very
long time yeah he he was crafty and he
was very hard to say no to um actually
the story in question though happened
with the opposite issue where we started
to notice that he was getting thin and
running hot he was like literally uh
warm to the touch uncomfortable and you
know he was not a fat cat but no but he
was Ling about miserable he became
inactive and he was not happy and what
it turned out was that he had a thyroid
tumor and cats have an interesting
difference uh from from us which is that
their thyroid is actually divided into
two now that divided into two plays into
the story very interesting interestingly
there is a uh a
marvelous therapeutic option in the case
of a cat with a thyroid tumor and it
works like this when a cat has a thyroid
tumor the thyroid that is Afflicted with
the tumor which is one of the two U uh
units that the thyroid is divided into
overproduces its product the body is
monitoring the products of the thyroid
and in response to the one side of the
thyroid overproducing the other side of
the thyroid shuts down because don't
need anym for me right so the animal
still has too much of the product but it
has one of its thyroids sidelined now
that actually allows you to cure this
disease in a very interesting way which
is you can give them radioactive iodine
which does not sound all that safe it is
uh pretty well regulated and it is much
safer than you would think um
radioactive iodine does not have a long
halflife and a an owner ameran actually
with a small number of uh precautions
control that I think we we had to be in
quarantine for a a week or so right and
we we kept him in a room alone and you
know we dealt carefully with his litter
box and all of that but anyway um you
give the animal the vet gives the animal
some radioactive iodine iodine is taken
up by the thyroid which is
um why you are instructed to take iodine
if you are in a a Zone where there has
been a radiological release um so that
you pick up non-radioactive iodine it
fills your thyroid and you don't pick up
any of the radioactive iodine uh that
has been uh produced in the reactor or
whatever but anyway the vet gives the
animal some radioactive iodine the
thyroid takes it up but not on both
sides because one side is shut down so
the side of the thyroid that is healthy
does not get the radioactive iodine the
side side of the thyroid that is torous
does pick it up and the nature of the
radioactivity is such that it destroys
the tissue only immediately adjacent to
where the iodine actually lands so it
destroys beautiful this is just such a
beautiful medical Veterinary same thing
right success story yeah it's just it's
it's taking advantage of this just lucky
fact that the thyroid is divided in the
cat um but anyway the thyroid the
tumorous part is destroyed by this but
the tissue even outside of it is is left
more or less intact because the
radiation doesn't penetrate very
far at the point that the thyroid that
was tumorous is destroyed the other one
begins to detect there's not enough
hormone being produced and it comes back
and the animal can live the rest of its
life with the other thyroid um
functioning and it does a fine job so
what we watched was an animal that
was uh I don't know that wasting wasting
away is probably a decent description
but he was
hot and uncomfortable and losing weight
and dwindling before our eyes and then
this uh actually put him right back on
track and he put the weight back on and
was again his healthy happy self it was
a it was a beautiful process but anyway
it goes to your question of um why does
an Agonist work right so um a ganad
tropen releasing hermone
Agonist uh uh effectively ultimately
shuts down your own body's production of
ganr and releasing hormone because by
flooding your body with it uh with this
synthetic version of it your body gets
the uh gets the message uh that it
doesn't need to produce any itself it's
already got enough it doesn't need to
produce any itself and if I this is the
first time I've encountered that
description of how this system functions
but it sounds like the key is that you
give a sustained dose and the response
uh is to a sustained dose is to shut
down production of the hormones that
would be involved in normal puberty
because what is otherwise delivered is a
pulsing dose and it is that pulsing dose
that is part of Health now that the
pulsatile thing is is remarkable like
we're also in addition to all the other
errors we're making we are not paying
attention to things like periodicity and
timing right periodicity and timing and
probably the pulsatile nature allows a
modulation that in that the system you
know is effectively able to check
with a periodicity where it is and
thereby modulate rather than just
turning the thing to 11 and it shuts
things down i' be I'd be curious what
happens at the end of normal puberty
whether you get a sustained signal or
something like that yeah and I don't um
I don't know that off the top of my head
um but you know there there are those
there are those people who would say
well yes obviously surgical intervention
for children is not not wise and oh we
don't want to put them on cross- seex
hormones because that's you know that's
not good but puberty blockers that's
harmless no it is not um I would not
want any child ever um I was going to
say anyone I cared about but any child
ever to be on any of these things um but
if I had to choose honestly I think if I
had to choose between um a child being
on cross- seex hormones versus being on
puberty blockers for a short period of
time I think the crossx hormones might
be safer because
because um you are you know boys do
produce some estrogens and girls do
produce uh some androgens and the ratios
are going to be messed up on cross- seex
hormones for sure uh but the puberty
blockers are messing with systems that
go way deep and are um you know are even
more ancient and are even more
fundamental in some ways and just to
reminder that you know the the
hypothalamus is
this incredibly important and Central
and
fundamental part of our brain and I'm
just going to read this one more time
from this physician uh from the rufo
interviews in this June 2023 piece in
City
Journal
uh I G read the whole this whole thing
one of the things I've been thinking
about is what puberty blockers do to
children this medication is called a
gonadotropin releasing hormone Agonist
and it comes in the form of monthly
injections or an implant and because
simulates the activity of this hormone
it shuts down the activity of the
hypothalamus the hypothalamus is this
almond size structure in your brain it's
one of the most Primal structures we
have and it controls all the other
hormonal structures in your body your
sexual development your emotions your
fight ORF flight response everything but
it shouldn't be described in such cold
physiological terms because your
hypothalamus is not just a hormone
Factory it's the system that allows you
to stand in awe of the beauty of a
sunset or to hear the sounds of
orchestral music and to stop whatever
you're doing and want to listen
and I always think that if someone were
to ask me where is it that you would
look for the Divine spark in each
individual I would say that it would be
somewhere beneath the inner chamber
which is the Greek derivation of the
term
hypothalamus to shut down that system is
to shut down what makes us
human yeah that is a um a stunningly
well articulated argument um I hesitate
to do this I do want to add something to
it it would be great to just simply
leave it there but the argument you're
making about children shouldn't be put
on any of this stuff but if you had to
choose you would choose the cross sex
hormones rather than the puberty
blockers I I think you're right and I
think that there is a very strong
analytical reason to presuppose that
that would be the less destructive
intervention and that is that what we're
really talking about is an intervention
that is Upstream of many processes and
the fact that it is Upstream of many
processes means yes you can interfere
there but you're interfering with
everything else that is Downstream which
is a tremendous number of important
things and some of we do not even know
right and that is really the thing and
much of it is not
reversible what I would want people to
understand when they are talking to a
scientist or a doctor or a
governmental uh
regulator about these interventions you
need to look at this person no matter
who who they are and you need to
understand they comprehend a tiny
fraction of what you would need to know
in order to do this well and fully
anticipate the consequences there is no
one on earth who knows the system well
enough to do that there might be
circumstances in which you have to make
choices you have to accept costs because
the pathology that you're faced with is
so severe that you don't have a better
choice we make make those those choices
we you know remove tissues that we don't
fully understand because they're
tumorous and we'll kill you if we don't
but in the case of somebody who is going
to go through development and then
you're going to interfere with something
as Central as the hypothalamus in uh
in adjusting some feature of their
pathway you are inherently interfering
with a tremendous number of things that
are simply black boxes from the point of
view of our current state of
understanding there's no way that that
could possibly be safe or reasonable to
do and in the case where you've got
again somebody with a mismatch between
their cognitive understanding of who
they are and their physiological nature
the cognitive intervention is a one that
people naturally go through and B much
more likely to work without having
devastating consequences getting a child
to understand that they that these are
the cards that they were dealt some of
them may be unfortunate some of them may
be just fine and really the reconciling
themselves to those cards is the way to
be but that is the nature of growing up
and interfering with growing up is
nobody's uh nobody's right these
children have a right to grow up as
normally as possible and that may be
perfectly normally and you're disrupting
that so it can never be undone so it
seems to me very very clear and that
this in a world in which people were not
feeling threatened by the accusation
that they were were
anti-trans then we would obviously be
able to talk about things like any
intervention should be as far Downstream
as possible the more Upstream your
intervention the more likely it is to
have devastating consequences you can't
anticipate that's right and I think you
know just having a bias towards
um interventions when you decide that
such things are necessary uh should be
as old and as
tested as possible um and and simply
having something be old um means that it
is likely to have been tested even if
not by science explicitly so um if you
tend towards depression there's a decent
chance that going outside in the sun and
moving your body hard uh will
help and you should do that first and
second and third and fourth and fifth
you should do that a lot of time before
you ever can
consider taking a pill for the fact that
you were
depressed you should not trust that the
interventions that the people with the
prescription pads are offering are the
right
ones we've moved into this this mode of
giving up assuming that we ourselves
have no agency at all but somehow these
other people with degrees that are
frankly meaningless or Worse have all
the agency and have all the wisdom and
it's not true I mean if if you can't see
how misled the people with the
prescription pads have been in the last
three and a half years like what why are
you still believing them when they come
to you and say I can solve that
dysphoria for you I can stop your
puberty I can turn you into something
you never were and never will be no they
can't and whether or not they're lying
to you or lying to themselves first
doesn't matter it's not going to help
you it's just not so this it's this is
this is madness and there are some
indications that it's turning around
that some people are waking up that the
number the number of people who know
people with trans kids is CL is so
outrageous now but it's it it can't be
soon enough this needs to have never
happened and second best is it needs to
stop all of it needs to stop now yeah we
we have to ma nobody else and by by
allowing this to continue every day that
it continues uh new people are uh pushed
into something that can't be undone
that's right you know it also occurs to
me there's something just so obviously
wrong here and I think uh many people
have spotted this but figuring out how
to how to say it so that it is generally
understandable is
important the idea of blocking
puberty
obviously um girls are not immature boys
so blocking puberty is it suggests that
medicine knows what to do after that to
create the equivalent of the puberty of
the other sex Which medicine absolutely
does not know how to do so at best what
it can do is it can simulate some
fraction of that either with surgeries
that create structures that aren't what
they appear to be or with hormones that
would be part of that process but are
hardly the sum total of that process so
we are inherently talking about a
medical arrogance where there are
doctors dumb enough to think they know
how to simulate the other puberty once
we blocked the one that you're headed
towards I guarantee you there are no
doctors that know how to do that there
just simply aren't we're not anywhere
close to that level of
knowledge I'm sure you're right about
what's actually happening but just so
you know what the argument is there they
will tell you that they block p and then
as soon as they stop blocking it it
comes back oh I know I know what they
say just do you know what their right
well again terribly arrogant argument is
that knows nothing about what will
actually happen but that's what they say
but dad's argument here is um that if if
those people on puberty blockers um do
decide to go down the path to
transitioning which again crazy um they
should be experiencing the puberty of
the other sex and um you know that's
that
that thing that you just said Zack um if
it were true would would be fine for
those people who experience puberty you
know who who have their puberty blocked
for six months and then go off them and
everything's as normal that's of course
not true um but the point there is uh
that uh we are told by the activists
that some number of these people are
actually trans and then they they're
going to need to have the other thing
and it's like well okay so um so you
decided that puberty just isn't a thing
at all you've just decide to go from uh
prepubescent boy to woman or
prepubescent girl to man like what what
happened to adolescence and Adolescence
despite what the postmodern idiots will
argue uh is not a creation of capitalism
or 20th century America or any of the
other insane things I've heard people
argue adolescence has always been a
thing and different cultures have
understood it differently but uh it you
know there is a stage between childhood
and adulthood and uh humans are not
totally unique in having such a thing
but uh we are um fairly rare and you
can't just we're not we're not freaking
butterflies and even if we were what's
going on in the Cocoon is something we
don't know exactly what's going on
either
so it's such incredibly incredible
arrogance it's such incredible hubris
and you know their their argument is
both wrong and also doesn't deal with
the situation which is supposedly their
preferred outcome
which is that you were born you were
assigned you were assigned a male at
Birth but now you've come to realize
that you're actually female and so we're
going to block your Purity and voila
turn you into a woman because that's
what it is that's it's that easy well
it's the same argument it's the same
misunderstanding about humans that they
have across the board would suggest that
genitalia and hormones are the only
things that make you male or female
right which if well lipstick yeah that
too but I mean this is seriously what
they think and if that were true
I don't know they still aren't anywhere
near being able to successfully do
anything but it would sort of make sense
at least no the the argument that they
are making does not stand up the only
thing that has caused it to uh get as
far as it has is the threat to anybody
who points out how absurd it is right
and in part in one of the things that I
really like about this you know short
piece everyone should go read this this
roofer interview with this doctor that I
read substantial portions of here today
um but his his point the the doctor
Point uh that when you affirm someone's
delusion you are affirming that they
should hate themselves as they currently
are and um to the degree that you know
the stats have been juked all over the
place with regard to like oh you know
trans people have the highest rates of
suicide like actually um this has been
uh debunked like this this is not true
but do people with mental he health
problems such as depression and autism
both of which are correl with being
gender dysphoric um are they more likely
to have suicidal ideation yes and um are
they perhaps more likely um to succumb
to such ideation to spend more time in
that space if they've been assured by
all the adults around them that they're
right in imagining that they are wrong
and bad and flawed well yeah how about
actually encouraging your child to be
who they are as opposed to what their
fantasy of what they are
is we could we could go on I could I
could keep ranting forever so we should
well I I do I want to add one more thing
which is that
um there is a very deep concern one
should have that the idea of spreading
that story about suicide also
predisposes people uh who discover that
this is not the solution to the problem
I mean you can imagine let's say that
you you're betrayed by civilization
you're not given a coh erent uh path
through development you have hormones
that disrupt normal development
pollutants as pollutants and your food
and your water and your air and all of
these things so things are not going
right and then somebody says hey you
know what I know why things aren't going
right it's because you were born in the
wrong body you'll see it'll change
everything and you believe them right I
can imagine a desperate person believing
them and then discovering and especially
in the first flush of The Agonist or the
like you it's a as as I've heard you
feel it's you're on you're on sex
steroids right at least it feels
different and and it at the very
beginning it feels different and it
feels exciting and you're like this is
it right this was I the Magic Bullet
that I've been waiting for this is it
and then if it doesn't work the point is
you've told people something about what
comes next and you had no right to tell
them that it's part of a manipulative
story that is built to uh get people who
would otherwise raise an objection to
not do it it for fear of what it might
lead to but the point is you are setting
people up to consider that as an option
when in fact the right thing to do is to
say
look we are all born into a world that
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense at the moment that is the nature
of modernity and the question is how to
figure your path through it and there
are ways and telling people that yes you
really are hateful the way you are and
uh we can make you into something that
wouldn't be was a lie can't do it on
your own right
our help it's not a cognitive question
you need doctors yeah um and you're
going to need doctors for the rest of
your life some people are just like that
they need a lot of help it's terrible
it's criminal it is it is Criminal it is
Criminal and we really are talking about
uh we're talking about Ming people we're
talking about Ming them psychologically
we're talking about Ming them
physiologically and morphologically all
three of those things are on the table
here with as a result of the standard of
care that we are being uh coerced into
accepting uh top down yeah and uh it's
despicable it really has to stop yeah I
agree all
right uh I think we've come to the
end we strongly encourage you to join us
at our locals uh Channel which you can
get to from rumble or from locals it'll
be in the show notes and and uh there's
a lot lot going on there the watch party
that goes along with our live streams
happens there uh we release the guest
episodes uh that you do uh a day early
there we did we've begun doing our
private Q&A uh live streams at our
locals and uh is Discord yet available
on our locals or is it about to be
actively actively happening okay awesome
um so that's that's going to be
happening very very soon so uh please
consider joining us there uh we really
appreciate it helps us out and uh it's
turning into a great
Community uh we also of course have a
store Darkhorse store.org and I write at
Natural Selections at my substack every
week and um I had a little thing some
things to say about um I mispronouncing
her name Megan rapo I've never actually
heard her her name but the uh the
extraordinary soccer player who's also
an extraordinary Trump hater I wrote
about her a little bit this week um
she's really really good at both things
she excels in two seemingly unrelated
disciplines yeah yeah um but I wrote
about her at Natural Selections this
week just a little bit and um and yeah
uh we've got we
got exciting things coming up uh in in
the near future but uh do consider
checking out the locals and also our
sponsors this week which I didn't change
them from last week's show notes our
sponsors this week were seed House of
academias and American Heart for gold so
um check them out uh share share the
video
uh like it subscribe and uh know that we
appreciate your support and your
enthusiasm for what we're doing here
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well
everyone